often on the show legible we check
people's yearbooks and things and I have
to say tonight bodes well for a chat
show on a chat show what do you want
well Jennifer Lawrence voted back in
high school most talkative years in a
row Oh two consecutive years that's very
impressive
yeah it was hard to get him this Chris
Pratt he was voted class clown oh my god
we didn't have no Knesset no let me
Oliver didn't have a yearbook but if
they had you might have got most likely
to win Princess Leia look-alike
competition really why is hack your own
hair yeah yeah incredible yeah I know
I'm trying to grow it again well I
wouldn't
did you yeah I was like he's like a
Buffon geez I know I was cool as well
you were cool trust me you were cool I
know that my brother looked exactly like
that
and he was the people as guy yeah thank
you yeah that's that was cool I'm
actually here's with it cuz in school II
I mean joking aside school can't be easy
because you you're dyslexic so that was
must be no yeah I was either pretty I
wasn't very academic excursions put it
that way and I was in what you would
call they call it special needs in those
days so I did five years of special
needs I know this wasn't the best for
your confidence just a fast-forward what
an inspiring thing so here's this guy
again it dyslexic in school ladies don't
I give you the best-selling nonfiction
writer in this country of all time ever
ever
[Applause]
Mrs Murphy bless you like the only
person who's had told you at all is JK
Rowling yes yeah but by quite a lot the
world don't get me wrong but like the
next level and now but I apparently your
your reading books now uh uh what okay
this is gonna make so that I can read
and but I I really struggled with
narrative books I always fell asleep
after twelve thirteen pages and then
when I saw Jennifer in Hunger Games I
loved it so much and you're amazing and
I wanted to see the next show
straightaway but I couldn't be bothered
to wait so I've got the book and I read
it which which for me it was a big deal
and anyone that's dyslexic will know how
that feels but um so yeah and it was
amazing to be have a place quite a place
where I could kind of get into it yeah
but I also I've just started wearing
glasses so I realized I'm blind as well
[Applause]
[Music]